[Music]
It's God. It's God. It's
God. It's God.
Are you a Muslim or a Christian? So, I
only believe in one less God than you.
So, that's how that's how I like to look
at it. You know, one less God. Yeah. How
so?
What do you mean? Like, uh you said we
believe in one God. You don't believe in
the God. I mean, I have a lot of
religious friends, right? And then
they're always like, "Why why don't you
go to church with us? Why aren't you
religious?" And I'm like, "Why don't you
go to why don't you go to the Buddhist
temple with me or something?" You know,
"Why don't you go to a Hindu temple or
anything?" Uhhuh. I only believe in one
less God than you. So what's the
difference? I I think the difference
would be I guess where what you
substantiate that in. Like if you say
you you're saying that there is no God.
So then you would have to That means you
have to say there is no God. There you
are. You're an atheist. Huh? You're an
atheist. An atheist is one who does not
believe a god exists. You're saying
there is no god. I'm just saying that
there's no evidence to substantiate
that. So why would I believe what would
evidence look like to you?
Uh I don't know. I I always tell people
I would need to become like a prophet to
you need to be you said you would need
to become a prophet. I would need to be
a prophet to believe in God. What What
about a simple guy? You can't be a
simple guy and believe in God. Like I
mean like he would need to speak to me
and at that point I'm a prophet, right?
You can't you can't see the evidence. I
don't think that's how you live your
life. Like I don't think that you live
your life by uh ab something has you
have to see it, touch it, feel it in
order for you to believe something. Uh
not necessarily. I mean there doesn't
need to be anything tangible. Presented
himself to me.
People have tried presenting to me, you
know. So then what would you say created
all of it? What how did all this get
here? I don't know. But like I I I I
don't know. Being an atheist, I'm not
saying I have the answers. I'm just
saying I don't have the answers. You're
saying that it's not God. I'm saying I
don't have the answers is what I'm
saying. All right. So, what what is your
reason for saying that it's not God?
What is your reason for that? I'm not
saying it's not God. I just don't have
the answers. Okay. But but you are
saying is Okay. When you say it's not uh
you're an atheist. An atheist literally
is atheism. No god. Theos. Call me
agnostic then. I guess I'm closer to
agnostic. So you don't know if God
exists or not? Uh no. Okay. So, you're
not saying for certain that God doesn't
exist, but you do you lean more toward
that he doesn't or that he does? Uh, you
know, it's hard for me to put that in
any such way, but there to me there's a
lack of evidence in the field that he
does exist. All right. So, let's talk
about that. Like, what do what do you
say? What what what are you considering
evidence as? Because, you know, evidence
points to I guess a reality or truth,
right? So, what is what would be
evidence that would point to God for
you? I don't know. You don't know. I I
really don't know what evidence there
possibly could be. What about like, you
know, I' I've read the Bible and then
Yeah. What about What about creation
itself? Apparently, creation itself.
Yeah. The world itself, the sky, the
universe, you animals, the eyeball, the
heartbeat. I don't know. DNA. Let me ask
you this. Does Does uh like cuz cuz you
you you're a man of science at all? You
I would say so. Okay. So when we follow
the scientific method things that we
know that point to things that we
understand as fact or whatever we it has
to be observable first it has to be
observable and then we u experience it
right we experiment with it maybe test
it out if we can or or whatever but
that's how we come to our conclusions so
looking at the observable
world have you ever experienced
something being as ordered as this is
and designed as it is coming from
something that is not intelligible.
Uh
I don't know. This is all I've
experienced, you know. I'm not So So
everything that you experience, this is
what I'm going I wouldn't say that it's
from something intelligent necessarily.
Okay. So that's what I'm asking. I think
there were a lot of pressures that
naturally set things up the way. You
know, I I believe in evolution. So
that's good and all. You if you believe
in evolution, then you believe you you
you understand that life comes from
life. Life doesn't come from non-life. I
believe in selective pressure. What?
What is that? Or sorry, I I don't even
know if that's the right term. Natural
selection. Natural I guess kind of. But
like uh I just think that you know over
the course of like millions of years
things will naturally optimize
themselves. So you have you have a faith
in that? Yeah. Yeah. You're expressing a
faith. Okay. But I don't I don't know
about a faith in that necessarily. But
it is cuz the data proves it. What what
data? Huh? Just uh when you look at like
past species like reasons they went
extinct or something. Oh, okay. They
couldn't metabolize as fast like
megalodons, you know, they went out cuz
there was not enough food but naturally
things became smaller. We're talking
about we're talking about life itself.
We're talking about why there is life in
the first place. Life always comes from
life. That's a scientific principle. So
if life always comes from life, then the
first life in the universe comes from an
original life source. That's just what
we've observed scientifically.
So that would mean that the physical
life that we see here had to come from
something beyond that. A life that is
beyond that. Mhm. Which what would you
call that? What does that point? That
points to a life beyond our realm is
what I'm saying. I think you have a
great point. I think you're making some
great points right now. Yeah. The only
point of contention I would say is, you
know, like how there's so many answers
to that question. There's not. There
aren't. That's the point. There isn't.
Like there's there's Okay, let me ask
you. There's there's Christianity,
there's Islam, Judaism. Oh, so you're
like so basically you're saying who is
that? You're saying who is that god or
how do you know that your god is the
right one? That's basically what you're
asking, right? Not necessarily. I'm just
saying there's like how can you put an
answer on it necessarily? Any one of
these? How can you put an answer on
evidence? We follow where the evidence
leads. If the evidence shows that one,
there is a a source of life. Evidence
points to a source of life. So we know
that a life exists beyond us that is the
source of all life. And then we look at
the evidence for who that life is. Is it
who the Christians claim it is? Is it
who the Muslims claim it is? Buddhist
who what is the evidence? Where does the
evidence lead? And that's where we
that's where we go. You know, I was
actually raised Buddhist. You was raised
Buddhist? Yeah, I was raised Buddhist.
Okay. Your parents your parents both of
them were were Buddhist. Are you still
Buddhist? Yeah. But I mean like Buddhism
is kind of a weird religion. Mhm. Like
my understanding of it as I grew up is
it's not a religion at all really. It's
just a philosophy pretty much. My
parents didn't believe in much outside
of like the principles. And then I would
always ask them like you know like do we
pray to Buddha like he's a god? They're
like no he's not a god. That's the point
though. So have you looked at they just
don't they just I don't know at least
the monks that I've met I'm a terra
Buddhist so that's like the original
one. Yeah. Yeah. They don't really try
to put answers on anything. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. They kind of leave it up and Yeah.
Leave it up to ambiguity. Yeah. They
don't really think there's a goddess. I
I don't need an answer. But but but you
would though because like I mean what do
you think happens after you die?
I don't know. I have to find out. If
there was a heaven if heaven and hell
was real, wouldn't you want to know
that? Uh you wouldn't want to wait till
you die to find out. I guess I would
want to know that. Yeah. Yeah. There's
no way you know that till I die. No,
that's that's not true, brother. Because
we have somebody that's that's, you
know, came and told us he died, rose
again on the third day and told us, "Hey
guys, there is an afterlife. There is a
heaven and a hell. And you have to, you
know, believe and live a certain way in
order to come where I'm where I'm where
I'm where I plan to bring you." That's
Jesus Christ. Jesus died and he rose
again. I choose to believe what he says.
And he and he tells us that he he says,
"Whoever believes in me, I'm preparing a
place for you and I'll take you back to
myself." So, he assures us of that. You
know, it's not guesswork. Yeah. You know
what I'm saying? I mean, that's that's a
dude from 2,000 years ago. You know, how
am I supposed to believe that? What do
you mean? How are you supposed to
believe that? That the the I don't know.
It It just sounds like a story. What do
you think history is? I think history
indicates actually that there's like,
you know, there have actually been a lot
of figures that are exactly like Jesus.
None. There are none like Jesus. I
forgot what his name. He's like uh No,
he's an Egyptian god or something.
Nothing. Yeah. Yeah. You're talking
about you got um Horus. Horus and Osiris
and and Iris. None. None of the none of
their stories are like Jesus at all.
Wasn't born of a virgin. Didn't you know
wasn't doing none of that. Didn't die
for our sins. There were there were a
lot of uh I think I think I watched a
documentary. Uh you heard it. Religious.
Religulous. No. Oh, okay. Oh, but by
Bill Mar you said? Yeah. Yeah. What an
idiot. He's an idiot. No. you don't like
I don't agree with everything that he
says. Yeah. But but what he's his his
whole goal is he's anti he's anti-Jesus,
bro. And he's uh he he loves propagating
information or false information
especially against Jesus. Anything
that's against Jesus, he tries to say
that there's a bunch of uh characters
that, you know, Jesus copied the story
over or people mimicked Jesus. Yeah.
Yeah. That's exactly what I'm saying.
And there's no historical basis behind
that. No source material behind that.
None at all at all. I mean like I've
done my own research too like uh yeah
there
uh in Egypt there were a lot of gods
that were son or like demigods I guess
maybe sons of virgins. There are none
none of them were sons of virgins.
There's not one in in Egyptology that's
a son of a virgin. You might want to
check it out. I have dude I have I mean
you should you should check out the
religious documentary. I I know what
he's I know what you're talking about. I
I've seen what he's what he does and
what he tries to point to. He us none of
the arguments he's using is new. His
stuff is not new. We've dealt with this
stuff years ago. Now, this stuff is
laughable. When you go to the source
material, there's nothing about Osiris
or uh Iris or uh uh uh I'm forgetting
the other the third one, the father. But
there's nothing about no virgin birth.
There's nothing about none of that, bro.
Being born on December 25th, all that
kind of crap. All of that is fake news.
There's no source material on that. It's
literally made up. Literally. Y are you
going to be here next week? No, I won't
be here next week. Oh, no. No. I'm going
to be here next week. But look look into
look into the historicity of Jesus, bro.
He has eyewitness testimony. He has all
of that. I necessarily believe you, but
you know, I would look into Yeah. Look,
that's all I can ask is look into it.
Look into the historical reliability of
Jesus. He's not just a myth. He's not
just a once upon a time there was a man
named Jesus, born of a virgin, raised in
Nazareth. No, it's in the time of
Capernicus and the king, you know, this
time, you know, this year and the year
of this reign, yada yada yada, you know,
King Herod and stuff like that. It's
historical documentary, not mythical. I
go to hell, man. You're my hand. Yeah, I
got you. I got you, man. It was nice to
meet you, bro. Nice to meet you, too.
Oh my god.
[Music]